European Union Regulators there have
fined meta 1.3 billion dollars for
violating the privacy of its European
users the EU is claiming that meta
illegally transfer transferred user user
data from Europe to the US opening up
those European users to surveillance
from U.S sources meta says it will
appeal the decision and the fine which
is the largest ever assessed on a social
media company is something they dispute
they called unjustified and unnecessary
what's really interesting here is the
top privacy regulator in the EU is
taking issue with this transfer of data
because it says that that spy agencies
within the U.S could access user data
from UK and EU residents